most days a lot of you don't hear too
much about us
some days these days holidays
you might hear about maybe a handful of
us
the first of us
the only to win that title
take that job run that fast
that far these are luminaries in their
own right
indisputably deserving the spotlight but
let's tell the rest of the story too
how over fixation on first
to the exclusion of everything else can
erase history
blot out the experiences of so many who
were
who are held back how hyping just the
same few names can feed scripts that pit
women against each other
as if there were only so much attention
to go around
but girls women and allies
always have come together to make
collective impacts and to make history
protesting police brutality and systemic
racism
advocating to end policies that punish
protests
sitting out whole seasons to focus on
social justice
[Music]
[Applause]
getting out to vote and winning
political seats as well
and when one win sparks more that
ignites a radiance uncontained by
any spotlight we are speaking out
against discrimination
violence objectification we are
fighting for representation equal pay
and parental leave protection
we have been fighting period poverty
public health crises
and the crisis of missing and murdered
indigenous women
most days a lot of you don't hear too
much about us
but as women's history month comes to a
close
we're here to remind you it's not just
one month
or one day it's every day
it's not just the few it's all of us
we ignite a radiance uncontained by any
spotlight
you're in its presence right now